sometimes there are stories that you are
told that you think are interesting
revelatory maybe even helpful to the
narrative there's nothing you have to
cover the story visually there's nothing
that you have to further illustrate what
someone's talking about and if you're
doing a movie and it's full of visuals
and you're trying to keep you're trying
to construct this consistent visual
palette even if it's on three different
sort of wavelengths as far as photos
footage stuff that you shot what have
you if you can't find something that is
consistent in a way that you can tell
that story and you have nothing
sometimes you just can't you just can't
use it and that's really frustrating and
sad especially when again we're talking
about truth and documenting events
frankly if something is so important you
figure out a way and sometimes it's like
you know we can't all shoot interviews
with six different cameras and so you
don't necessary have the luxury of I'll
just cut all different ways to make sure
it's fine and so you get creative
there's a scene in the movie that is
probably 5 and 1/2 hours in the movie in
part for the documentary where you've
gone through most the trial it's become
the media circus that it is and all of a
sudden we get to this the deputy the
deputy da bill Hodgman clinically taking
you through his version his belief of
what happened the night of the murders
on June 12 1994 so he had given me a
presentation in his office in the DA's
office in Los Angeles a couple weeks
before I sat down with and did an
interview and he went through this
slideshow presentation that he gives to
people in law enforcement when he talks
about that case and included is you know
he gives pictures included these
pictures of the murder scene now when we
did the interview I said hey bill do you
mind just sort of running through that
and giving me your version of events
that you you know so for six and a half
minutes he sat there and clinically went
beat by beat of what happened that night
and even listening to him it was chilly
and there was an argument by some
who I was working with that said just do
that just have him talk you know again
this notion of what is truth he it's his
version of what he believes it's there's
no videotape no one knows exactly what
happened but he's telling us and so
there's first of all an instinct to say
oh I don't want to edit this at all it's
so well it's so graphic it's so personal
to sort of what he that twenty years
he's spent thinking about this it's so
specific I want to include everything
and then you go well you know what I
can't just have six minutes of a guy I'm
through this is the sort of practical
life as a filmmaker well I just can't
have six minutes of them on screen
saying this and also what's the best
version of this scene is that that him
purely Rekha let you know recollecting
about what he thinks happened or can we
add visuals can we turn this in to a
more emotionally wrenching anecdote than
him just sitting in a chair and then
when you know that actually there are
these murder photos as photos the crime
scene that exists and they aren't photos
by the way that I might feel compelled
to otherwise use except for the fact
that here's a guy in his position
clinically dispassionately going through
what he believed happened that is almost
the only way I would have ever thought
of using such graphic photos because
there is a real purpose to it there's a
real purpose to understanding the
brutality of the crime and there's a
real purpose for you to sit there and
realize like you need to deal with what
is happening here what happened you need
to deal with the way that this guy is
talking about it so soberly versus the
spectacle that this trial has become you
need to as a viewer stop and whatever
you think of OJ Simpson why don't you
look at this and why don't you see if
you can look at him the same way after
that now the point being is that that
scene ends up being this horrific thing
now there's no music there's sound
design but there are - there's so many
choices that go into how am I going to
portray this especially the Tres portray
something and it's
sensitive and that could be absorbed in
so many different in different ways by
so many people and so that's those are
the things that are sort of you have to
really make sure that you are making the
correct choices
[Music]